i said once before i feel like benjamin
button
i was born old and i will die young a
reporter asked you
if you had any scars on your face and
you said
you should ask your wife you get that
you answer me a question
you get an answer when you come from my
neighborhood you
the first thing you wanted was to have a
cool car so i bought a porsche turbo
with my last money and i was driving
driving fast because i liked the
adrenaline and then suddenly police was
chasing me
so i ask you now do you think i stopped
or not
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation what's up believe nation
it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you i believe you have
michael jordan level talent at something
and i want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who went from growing up in the
ghetto and almost quitting on his
football career at age 15 to work in the
docks
to becoming one of the best strikers and
greatest football players of all time
he's zlatan ibrahimovic and here's my
take on his top 10 rules to success
volume 2. enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be confident
were you uh confident before soccer
or is football what brought you
confident no no before soccer because
from the area where i came from you
needed to be tough
i mean it was a rough neighborhood
i like it for me it's paradise people
call it ghetto i call it paradise
because i feel
i feel home i feel i can be myself
even if i'm doing that now also but in
that area it was like
you don't ask for respect you take your
respect
that is the the attitude was
you don't ask for uh let's say signature
when i go back there now
they don't ask for pictures they take
the picture so
that was the style that was the attitude
and and you needed to show that you
could
stand up for yourself and and be there
dominant so that came from there then
the football was just a
thing i like to do
rule number two don't chase money i saw
a report
that you turned down a hundred million
dollar offer from a chinese club to come
here
and play in los angeles we don't mean to
get all in your business but for what we
hear
three years uh two years rather three
million dollars for foreign why
why that's 97 million dollars left on
the table i mean
i mean this is this is a big challenge
for me i want to come over here
to the us play for galaxy and show
show everybody what what i'm able to do
and
it's not about the money because i
didn't even know my contract i had here
so
i just said prepare and i'm coming and i
think even
galaxy was surprised so like i said
after my injury i just want to be happy
i push it every time i put on the
football shoes and
just smell the grass touch the ball and
and do what i've been doing for the last
20 years and
and trust me that has no price rule
number three
give people what they want let's go back
to the
your first game here yes you're playing
la football club and you were hearing
chants in the stands right weren't you
slot
and slot we were hearing we want zlatan
we once let them and i said listen it's
time to give them zlatan
so i came in and i gave them zlatan
so it went good no oh
very good we cannot complain
[Applause]
[Music]
rule number four make no excuses
you described yourself on the pictures
believing you were a lion
is that right i am a you are a lion are
there enough lions around you in this
team
listen i will be honest to myself the
table is not lying
i think the team is where it is because
it is what it is
if we would be number one we would be
number one
top four for me it's last time i came
second i don't even remember that it was
in milan
ac bella ac milan you didn't like that
no you said it was something you weren't
used to that was the first
position of the last ones so that i
don't really like and they describe that
season as a failure
it is a failure so this whatever happens
whatever comes
after the first one is a failure rule
number five
grow from difficulties my father was
working a lot
my mother is a cleaner my father was
like taking care of
how do you say buildings and if
something was wrong
so they were not always there because
they needed to work to to bring in the
economy and i was living at my father's
house
but i was running over to my mother to
eat food
because i needed food but and then she
was complaining that i eat for four
people person so she kicked me out and i
was not allowed to eat everything so
i read i read a story about you where
you say that when you were coming to
your dad's house and you'd open the
fridge because you were hungry all that
was there was beer right
yes was there more or less beer
milk and butter and then bread
outside so that that was my breakfast
lunch and dinner when i was at my
father's place
but he did his best he could to give me
a good
good childhood good raise how do you say
so
i'm very thankful for that because we we
didn't have it better than that
were you a good bicycle thief yes
very good i have i'm still a good myself
even though you've retired you're still
you're okay how many bicycles did you
steal give me
give me an example of how the business
enterprise work i mean
like i said my father was working we
didn't have
the economy was not great it was less
than less and
i i had like i know the measures in
in the kilometer kilometers i don't know
more less than yours how much it but 10
kilometers so it was pretty far to go to
the training so
sometimes i was walking sometime i was
jogging
running and and i said i need a bicycle
and my father didn't have money to buy
one so
i went on the streets and i was looking
for first opportunity to steal one and i
stole it
came to the training and yeah came back
but when
when they caught me i was like i
borrowed the bicycle i didn't seal it
here take it back you're renting without
money
exactly rent for free
rule number six just be yourself when
you said you were looking for a
hotel room and if you couldn't find the
hotel room in paris or someplace
if i can't find it i'll just buy the
hotel yes
now you must really have it like that
huh
yeah we find a way we will find a way to
buy it
but you like being out there you like
being
controversial maybe i mean
i'm just myself i'm confident i
i say what i think i say we're not
almost what i want if it's right or
wrong we can discuss
okay let me see if this is true too a
reporter asked you
if you had any scars on your face and
you said
you should ask your wife exactly exactly
mundo you
obviously you did say that yeah because
i feel sometimes the question
is provocative and it's so he put the
level
and answer on his level you get you
answer me a [ __ ] question you get a
answer sometimes it's like that i don't
like to be political because i
i see too many athletes too many
personalities out there
they do it political they build up an
image that is not
the original one they want to be the
perfect one in this world nobody is
perfect
we all do mistakes i do a lot of
mistakes i learn from my mistakes
and i will redo mistakes and i will
learn again from my mistakes because
nobody is perfect i'm not trying to
to play theaters or to act or something
i'm just i am myself trust me i take it
serious in everything i say like
and i believe in the things i say so
then is the level of
of the like i said like the question and
that but
i'm confident i'm not arrogant i'm i'm
super confident i know
when i want something i will get it when
i believe in something
i will achieve it and i have my visions
and you walk it like you talk it exactly
rule number seven don't compare yourself
to others
who's the best striker in the premier
league right now for me i like a striker
that makes the difference
for me a striker doesn't only score
goals for me a striker is
he creates chances he make the other
ones better phil lukaku is strong
maybe he's not all-round player he's
more the
the physical player that scored a lot of
goals
aguero is good you didn't say yourself i
was expecting you to say me
liars they don't compare themselves with
humans
[Music]
rule number eight be a conqueror this is
just a new adventure for me
a new challenge and i'm looking forward
to conquer the the us just like i
conquered europe so
i'm i'm pumped after
20 years in europe playing for the best
clubs
in the world best with best players in
the world
i've been winning so much i think what i
collected
it's time to move to a different
continent i think you say so
move over to us try the mls
for me there was no question about it
galaxy was the team
and i chose them so they didn't need to
choose me i chose them and i
come to do exactly what i've been doing
the last 20
23 years winning because i feel
it's in my dna wherever i come i won and
i will still do it so
i'm coming to win i'm coming to help and
make it better
rule number nine prove them wrong i feel
i feel young i said once before i feel
like benjamin button
i was born old and i will die young this
is for sure so
just to say don't worry about my age i
know i'm 37 but
when i came to england they all said i
was old
i came in a wheelchair after three
months
i conquered england and they say i was
flying so
this is only numbers
[Music]
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip
is live on the edge what would you say
was the wildest
most fun time in your life what age were
you
around 18 19 i mean
when you come from my neighborhood you
the first thing you wanted was to have a
cool car so i bought a porsche turbo
with my last money i even borrow money
to buy it because i wanted to have a
nice car
was driving around and i was driving
fast because i liked adrenaline and then
suddenly police was chasing me
so i asked you now do you think i
stopped or not
no you didn't stop i didn't i drove i
drove until i found that tune
tunnel underneath the highway and i was
waiting there and
and they kept going so these moments are
like i don't say it's good
i don't say it's positive but it's the
adrenaline
that i was looking for to get sometimes
and where i come from
was normal let's say but it's not normal
but i miss those moments
because i like to live on the limit i
don't like to stop for the red guy on
the
traffic light when was the last time the
zlatan couldn't get into a restaurant or
couldn't get into
a nightclub does that happen in los
angeles because maybe they don't
know who the zlatan is so far i didn't
have any problems but
if it will happen i'll buy the
restaurant i'll make it a
parking place
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
now i've got a really special zlatan
bonus clip on how to be a lion but
before that
question the day i want to know which
clip resonated more with you
don't compare yourself to others or
don't chase money
don't compare yourself to others don't
chase money leave it down the comments
below let me know what you think thank
you guys so much for watching
i believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love i'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clip
we are all professionals we all get
judged for what we do
our professional work is to play
football
in my world i get judged after every
last training
and every last game i do is part of the
game
if you come up among lions
you should expect to get attacked by the
lions
is normal because if you're a cat you
will run away but if you're a lion you
will stay among the other lions
that's my world that's where i come from
i came to england i came here as a 35
year old where everybody thought i was
in a wheelchair
and what happened the lion is still
alive
and that's the way it is we are on a
professional level we are on the top you
want to be on the top
you should you should expect everything
can
can come to you and you need to be
strong to
the way you handle it and the lion heats
up
everything altruistic world domination
honey empire right i'm grateful i
understand
why i'm here i think because i am so
open i wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous
success if you want to know what garyvee
dj khaled
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video